take it away john guys it's time for
squid game episode seven of season one
this episode is called vips hey thank
you all for joining us leave a like on
this video if you like it leave a
dislike if you don't like it it's all
engagement at the end of the day hit
that subscribe button and as always over
on our patreon page we have watch alongs
full length where you sync up with the
time code for squid game as well as
watch longs and reaction highlights for
various other shows you're probably
seeing a bunch of thumbnails up there
right now we have a lot of fun over
there and last but almost certainly not
least
most certainly not least prepper thank
you to the team over there for editing
down these highlights let's just jump
into it
[Music]
where have they been for the last four
games
[Music]
[Laughter]
revert them back to their most childlike
purest instincts this whole game
it's like a cackling witch man yeah
the wire's different
i know i knew it
[Laughter]
it's not too late to play the game you
know
oh boy
i feel like you need your peripheral to
be able to enter rooms and stuff like
that yeah to secure any kind of area
especially with this poorly lit as all
these rooms are
these my christmas presents still dude
homeboy is detail oriented i know
oh what a shot
okay oh i thought it was his radio
dude why would you leave that on
well the body he threw out probably
yes
oh that's right
crap battle
[Laughter]
good reference thanks oh hell yeah
dude everyone's down to the wire man
we'll come way too far for this man
where is the host unfortunately some
urgent business has prevented him from
attending
i just have to say that i'm a difficult
man to please i hope you won't
disappoint me
shall
[Music]
out the most we
sigh what are the odds these dudes are
all going to live through this no
no don't do it you you [ __ ] put a lot
of money on that [ __ ] to win oh
no
what convinced you 2-bit so much your
number 69. oh it's uh such a beautiful
number
you depraved lunatic
[Music]
oh they didn't even realize he killed
himself
oh
wow
he succeeded nobody stopped him
[Music]
looks like your little motivational
speech didn't help man
well as massive as the show is i weirdly
don't want it to end i know
like oh no really a couple of
of these sick games
oh my god this really is the eyes wide
shut club yeah
what's that thing i like the looks of it
what the hell is that you guys are so
over the top
[Laughter]
they're the rich and powerful elites
[Music]
his phone also has the best battery life
i've ever seen any phone they got
advanced technology
[Laughter]
grab your vest early
against the rules
now we just let fate decide and wait
[Music]
good to know
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
first or last
great
wow
oh
now the game will begin
oh no
it's fascinating to get it through their
lens
whoa is this gonna this is a tv or is
just right before them
[Music]
i don't believe it
oh my god it's like that
what's that fault fall game whether it
is
[Laughter]
he finally takes ownership of a choice
and hey man you want to trade yeah first
or last is the worst position to be in
unless
going last just means everyone's broken
the regular glasses
that's the point that's the game
i don't want to have to keep calling you
back
sit down i must deserve the other guest
to sir
i'm gonna keep this one next to me any
objections he's all yours
as he likes sexually drawn to him
i don't know i wouldn't put anything
past these guys probably
and you have to jump to one
okay
that's why you don't want to be last
remember the order remember the order
people
[Music]
you knew it what pretty eyes you have
oh he's just gonna whip out his gun oh
man
oh actually if your last it could help
yeah if you're guihoon all you got to do
is keep your balance and be
oh quick bet there's no real rhyme or
reason
there's got to be a way to tell by
looking at them oh my god it's so
transparent man
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow is that how he's been going through
this whole game probably yeah using that
math degree
oh my dude oh no
oh man i had hope's room yeah
yeah i was wondering if they could go
more than one at a time
yeah that'd probably help yeah at the
time with the timing at least
just to jump to the next one it's so
scary sucks to be the first person every
time
he went left he went left
i think i don't know
this is what happened man that's the
problem with eyewitness testimony
queen too yeah
his last words are going to be you [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now you're first
take that mask off i want to see your
face is he allowed to
i don't think so but i don't know
oh
wow
oh wow that's some ring
oh no
[Music]
my dude
[Music]
the lord cleared a path for him
[Music]
or okay i was like maybe they just broke
the glass maybe
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think that is the most quintessential
moment of this show
[Music]
[Music]
hell yeah man boy
gotta remember the pattern let's run
down the two center bars
[Music]
i was so scared of heights this would be
like
i would panic
what
thanks
where we can be alone
yeah
you're living at the most exciting
moment but you all have fun
i'm going off
for a different kind
he got real 69 huh
[Music]
oh my god
oh yeah
[Laughter]
if you
can satisfy me in five minutes i'll
change your life
[Laughter]
come on you gotta have a knife or
something
if you can satisfy me in five minutes
i might literally
oh my dude everything you know about the
game
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they just bounced off
yeah
and he even makes sure to make the game
piece bounce off his gamepiece
she's been awfully quiet this whole time
[Music]
[Music]
holy crap
[Music]
hoot
[Music]
oh
foreign
oh he's going to slip up though he's
gotta
or maybe he's just lucky 13. he is
i mean it seems
damn he's doing it
my dude
according to his file
he wants to have a job at a glass
manufacturer
that's no fun i think he's examining the
refraction of the light let me adjust
the settings how you dick
that's not fair
off
[ __ ]
seems to have done the trick
these guys
yeah
game master the front man guy must be
pissed right now
oh man
wow that marvel does the trick that is
oh that's amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
he's gonna push him
i mean he's always got a good reason for
why he excuses man so he's got some
reasoning
no matter how ruthless it is
[Music]
wow it's just down to them three huh
[Music]
wow
cover your face cover your yeah duck and
cover
your face oh
yep yep yep
damn what a shot
whoa
whoa what a hell of a shot man
oh no
[Music]
no
no no no
secret agent man secret
this guy's a not detective he's a spy
he's got like the most
cutthroat survival skills he's not been
eating he's been on his eyelid all this
time
cunning cunning is a better word
[Music]
whoa what an episode
that'll live below the surface now what
an episode
that's that's damn good television
that's damn good tv damn i'm gonna take
you back man give me more
and my american sensibilities those are
the rich guys in that luxury eating room
yeah yeah
number six died live
it's fun i'm sorry
but what [ __ ] game was that that they
played as a kid is that is there a game
that i don't know yeah i don't think so
i mean there are games that you play
where you're like trying to balance
across stuff but
crossing a glass bridge like i don't
know
it's like it's kid like usually i
imagine maybe you could fall into like
um like the
jungle gym balls yeah like maybe
something
yeah yeah like maybe if you went to one
of those like big activity places like
maybe they have something where like oh
one side's solid and the other side will
drop you into a big pit full of foam is
that thunder or someone on the roof
[Music]
that's thunder
is it raining it's a thunderclap
open that window
it doesn't appear to be raining
but sometimes there's thunder and
something evil is coming yeah that's
right
evil dark
portents yeah that was um
that was wildly intense
i didn't realize that man killed his
wife at the top yeah when they did that
yeah he just had this like little what
they've what this episode really hit me
like really
really hit me with is how good they are
telling
not just their main character stories
but these short stories of people like
you see the husband and wife when
they're introduced like i have to stick
with my wife uh on that first game and
then them choosing each other obviously
partnered up when it came to the marvels
and then here like he ended up killing
like they just had this like short story
or even the one guy who was doing like
counting numbers and the percentages in
his head you know like they feel like
they have like a backstory for every one
of these players who's been able to
stick around and the way they flush them
out so well to the point where even
though the most minor roles seem to be
so well developed and so well thought
out and i find that just it just makes
this whole thing just feel that much
more alive yeah that much more lived in
and it makes you care that much more
whenever you get these little bits of
dialogue with each player
that give you a hint to the kind of
history they had prior going into here
that makes you just feel the loss of
each one of their lives yeah as they all
plummet to the
that sad sad ground
i wonder how each of them chooses to
cope like you know yeah you see
everybody's coping mechanism with the
world they're thrown into whether it be
this game or probably like the rest of
life like it's yeah it's a nice little
cross section of when met with the
challenge yeah this guy is crunching the
numbers this guy's praying profusely
this guy is going to talk a big game up
until the crucial moment and then
throw down a barrier that he just won't
move and like having that be the resolve
to uh uh
duck so uh the the gangster guy
uh like that was
i thought they they brought that to a
nice baby
with her too yeah she heard this whole
show
at that moment i was like you're my girl
what's the one thing you could do to get
back on the the best of grace's take
this out which i mean i really loved
watching both of their performances but
yeah it was sort of a thing where oh
yeah don't get me wrong yeah i gotta
interrupt really quick to say like as
much as i hate the characters i think
their performances are amazing yeah yeah
i'm gonna miss the actors but at the
same time it was like oh yeah take them
down like you know like yeah you're
probably not gonna make it through this
and it'll probably be way more
satisfying for you to take one out on
this guy the second she like was behind
him good and i thought they played that
so smart is so coy of them of how they
they did she's usually this like
obnoxiously
bombastic
uh just exuberant whiny complaining
personality yeah like overdoing it
trying to be like cool to everybody like
hey babe how's it going
and she was kind of quiet and then you
forget about her yeah so when they do
the reveal that she's the one who pushes
the guy behind him and then she's
standing behind him like that was such a
great like oh damn forgot about you hey
you know
well well played man
and then yeah when she's
you just know she's like this is this is
the thing she kept saying that i'm gonna
kill him she treated this guy like he
was in she was in some like long-term
relationship with this man i know
well in here i mean it's the most solid
relationship she's had
well she's got this like sociopath like
her character just suddenly clicked for
me in that moment this like almost uh
for american reference i would say a bit
of like glenn close fatal attraction
status
of like she's someone who's insanely
insecure about her age and her
appearance like that's just such a
trigger point for her to be called that
she's she's desperate on selling herself
in every way or winning whether that's
like pleading for sympathy and pity or
trying to sell that she is like overly
skilled you know one or the other and
then she she sleeps with this guy who
she put all her faith and then he
betrayed her and it's just like it all
became about getting revenge on this
dude who she knew over a few days
like she is like this a psychotic
obsessed person and
by the end of in her final moments i'm
like you know scarecrow's the [ __ ]
like [ __ ] insane
and then she even becomes like a
cackling witch at the beginning of this
episode it's like insanity i love it
well i love too yeah the way that they
come back in and they're like you got to
you set the whole game out you have to
go through any of that stuff
which you know in one breath you can see
coming but at the same time it was very
rewarding for her to be like yeah they
just took me outside kind of called me a
loser for not having anybody who wanted
to play with me and brought me back in
here and i guess that's their version of
fair called the weakest link yet yeah
she took down the strongest one on the
team mm-hmm
um and then our our other guy oh my god
i'm so seven episodes i think what is
seoul university's guy's name oh
[Music]
this show does a good job such a great
job and the actor is phenomenal at this
to it painting him in this light of man
you are ruthless
but i
i gotta get
you don't look like you're enjoying
being ruthless but man are you
up every like crucial point where
ruthlessness or cunning needs to factor
in he's always got it you want to just
be like you're an [ __ ] but then you
asked me like what would you do yeah i
get it yeah
no other choices man
even sad to say even with ollie was like
did i like the manner in which he
handled the matter with ollie absolutely
not however like i get it man you had to
win you had to win dude and um
right down to here too you know he just
pushed this guy like this dude who
helped him get across here but like this
guy's not making a decision i'll make it
for us
and
as as like as this guy just becomes
colder and colder as this show
progresses
and you're like man what an [ __ ]
but i get it yeah it's so
strong yeah and who's this guy if this
guy gets out and gets to bring a little
salvation to his family who on earth is
he gonna be
at that point because too it's like you
look at gihon and and the way that he's
made it through and i mean granted
there's luck and there's all kinds of
things but it seems like
he would probably have a lot less like
guilt on his hands leaving this yeah you
know than somebody like sang woo wood
wow yeah that was awesome and that
explosion too at the end to just drive
it home like oh it's crucial it's good
that we just got off the glass i mean
it's incredibly movie like that these
three there are three main characters it
would come down to the three last
players right it's very movie-like so i
imagine the next episode be like calm
before the storm
but i really don't know who'd walk out
the window this show's so depraved and
so dark you know like i i don't know who
would win
i you thinking like cinema wise it would
come down to somehow
the you know gihan and the pickpocket
late what's your name
i i can see the smelly yeah yeah that's
sabio or something yeah um
like you're coming down to them too
maybe they split the reward or something
like that
um
but i could also see a scenario where
the other guy wins there totally he just
takes out the other two you know yeah
and you're like what's yeah what's the
ultimate morale can it only be one
winner or can there be two winners i
think they said
i mean i don't know how they how they
matched it out but the impression i got
was there can be more than one winner
like if for i got the sense there could
be like a handful even okay yeah and
then of course getting to meet the vips
yeah who um
it it's effective and it is the first
time i've actually had a criticism about
the show
like
they are so
it's weird because it feels very
intentional so my criticism is not heavy
uh however i still think it's it feels
like they got you know like they're it
feels like bad actors but at the same
time everything feels intentional yeah
just like this really over the top like
let's take the most one-note cardboard
cutouts of a wolf of wall street s type
of character and plucked them in here
and it they just they kept cutting back
to them for like the most they're just
it was like those animes that just point
out what's happening on screen yeah like
yeah we know and they're just pointing
it out and sitting and cackling and yeah
yeah it was like frustrating but
abandoned to get you to hate those guys
so i don't want the takeaway of that i
[ __ ] hate it when it's like you talk
about a gazillion good things out of a
half hour video and then you say the one
thing they're like well actually greg i
disagree and if you want to do that fine
that's up to you um but i don't want
that to be the main takeaway because
that's not the main takeaway from me
uh i i personally just thought like they
could have been written a tad bit better
at the same time i can't sit here and
say that it's not effective in getting
you to go man these sleazy [ __ ] you
guys are so because even with like our
our mass front man you know i i think
there's like there's there's layers
underneath that i don't quite know how
to articulate or i don't personally know
the details of but you can feel there's
something more to him and the dialogue
that he has and i thought like
i don't really know what i would have
wanted to be honest maybe that is the
best option of how they did it it just
felt like very didn't feel
the first thing that pulled me out of
the believability of it
yeah i think there's something
interesting about and you brought up
kind of it being sort of hollywood-esque
or you know in the hollywood economics
of character versus story it's like okay
we have our three kind of central
figures making it to the end of the game
and i think they've done a really
good job of advancing a lot of you know
the people that you're bonded to most in
ways that feel natural in ways that feel
like they just scraped by and so in that
way for the most part i think they avoid
that sort of hollywood armor with that
however on the opposite side of the
story the most cliche thing that yeah
it's like i i i'm enjoying it as part of
this world and it's kind of what you
would imagine is waiting
not in the show yeah yeah and i was even
sitting there thinking yeah if they had
just like done something a little more
nuanced or given us maybe a bit more of
a window of what they're like with each
other when they're not watching the game
or something outside the game before we
get to the game uh yeah it's like that
was the side where i was like okay this
more feels like now like a hollywood
movie but
uh at the same time yeah it does feel
like they are caricature by intent and
you know they're at least like fun and
icky to watch and they serve their
purpose yeah yeah that's what i mean
that's like the little conflict here
is that it it works it's effective and
it feels in purple it feels it doesn't
feel like they didn't hit the mark on
what they wanted to hit
so that's why i can't really i'm not as
bothered by it only because i'm like
well this feels purposeful yeah
especially if they make something more
or reveal more about what position the
front man is in because he even said
like the games master's not here yes
it's me
and uh the host the host yeah yeah and
uh and sequel there you go season two
but i'm wondering like okay so are they
gonna make it so that like these guys
who are watching truly kind of exist
outside of any consequence to the world
plot et cetera that is happening on this
island as maybe the the uh front man is
subject to all that because as terrible
as some of the things that the soldiers
do or have admitted to doing it seems
like they are also kind of
caught up and somewhat victims of the
system that begets this game so maybe he
is too and maybe you know they are there
to illustrate a certain gap between even
him and you know
the elite delete delete delete delete
you know
i hope our detective is able to get out
of here alive
so hope so man i hope someone's good
getting all his texts he's like he's the
only action hero in this show yeah
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below hit that like button subscribe
click that bell last but not least let's
do a
jason dolan my man i recently uh i just
saw you yesterday i had lunch with you
and
it's a great time i always love when you
get to visit california and of course
like a channel that he helps run kazzy
reacts i wanted to shout this out she
just covered a movie that we are
planning to cover this month called
train to busan movie reaction i haven't
seen it yet but i breezed through some
comments and because i didn't want to
get a movie spoiled for me and i saw the
like to dislike ratio very very positive
response so guys go check out kazzy
reacts reaction to train to busan and
jason thanks for being such an amazing
friend man
[Music]